So let's go back to our question of why
we need consistency. We have already seen an example
in our quiz, that something beyond coherence is needed
for our data-ready flag synchronization to work. Another similar
example is thread termination, where a thread creates another
thread. Now that created thread, let's call it B,
does a lot of work and updates some data.
While thread A goes and waits until B exits.
And it really happens by doing a system call in
thread A and then the system really will wait for B
to mark that it's done. And then when thread B really
is done, the operating system will mark the B is done.
And here we have a very similar situation inside the operating
system that we have here. Which is the check for B
exiting might be branch rated and then confirmed while in fact
thread B is not done when we branch [UNKNOWN] like this.
So what we need is some sort of additional set ordering
restrictions that are going prevent the weird situations that we get
into without any consideration for consistency. And again, this goes beyond
coherence alone, we already saw that coherence doesn't really help us here.